hong kong's fight against an
increasingly authoritarian state
has found a very vocal supporter in the
government of taiwan
in an exclusive interview to dw its
foreign minister joseph wu
has called pro-democracy protesters
freedom fighters
and promised moral support wu's words
are in line with the stand the
government of taiwan has taken since
anti-government protests broke out in
hong kong last year
here's more of what wu had to say
we try to give support moral support
to those freedom fighters in hong kong
and we continue to urge the hong kong
government
to adopt free election and to ensure
freedom
especially freedom of speech and freedom
of media
so that hong kong can stand as a symbol
of freedom
in east asia but as it's
very unfortunate that the chinese
government will impose national security
law
on hong kong and after that
you know we saw uh the election
scheduled
later this year has been postponed for
one year
the rights of the hong kong people has
been taken away by the chinese
government
the last bastion of freedom of press the
hong kong
apple deity has been under assault
by the chinese authority there are
politicians especially on the democratic
side
that have been disqualified by the
chinese authority or by hong kong
authority
and that is a gross violation of
political rights in hong kong
so this whole situation in hong kong is
really a tragedy
let's get more from dw correspondent
william yang who conducted that
interview and joins me now
from taipei william taiwan is clearly
concerned
but in reality how much of a difference
can it make
when it comes to the situation in hong
kong
so in the interview that we conducted
with the foreign minister joseph wu
he clearly pointed out that taiwan's
biggest difference
from falling into the similar situation
like hong kong
is to rely on its sovereignty and also
its democratic system and the government
that is always
elected by the people in taiwan so
in a way that is very much aligned with
what the administration has been
strengthening and
re-emphasizing over and over again over
the last few years
which is that the democratic value is
playing a very important role
for taiwan to continue to strengthen its
independence
from in any sort of interference or
impact
politically from china and the taiwanese
voter as we have seen over the last few
years
have been also exercising their
democratic rights uh
at a historic highway uh we have already
seen over the last few elections that
the turnout has been uh surpassing the
past
so that just also shows that the tony's
society is receiving the message that
the taiwanese foreign minister is hoping
the international community will receive
as well
william there's more to talk about on
that front but foreign minister wu also
addressed china's alleged expansionism
in the region
and its challenge to the rules-based
international order let's just listen in
to what the foreign minister had to say
i think it's not only about china's
expansion
their expansion their ambition to you
know uh
occupy uh territorial waters or
territories
in this region i think they are also
interested in changing
the international rules of the game uh
they
are trying to export the authoritarian
international order
while uh the democracies are following
the rule-based international order
i think it's going to be a moment where
the international freedom
and democracy needs to be very concerned
about
and as i said you know we are standing
on the front line
we understand our own our own
responsibilities and we'll do
everything we can not only to protect
ourselves
but also to protect freedom and
democracy democratic way of life for the
international community
william yang our correspondent is still
with us on the line william the foreign
minister says
taiwan is on the front lines against an
expansionist china
but is it getting any help
internationally in the trenches
so since 2019 we have actually seen the
increased frequency of different
countries
sending their warships through the
taiwan straight and the frequency have
also
triggered a more heightened response
from china
and at the same time the u.s has has
been actually
approving a lot more military cells to
taiwan over the last four
years and so these are all feeding into
taiwan's growing preparedness and also
at the same time the
capability of its military in order to
prepare for
all kinds of scenarios for the chinese
military invasion
and uh during the interview mr minister
who also pointed out the very important
thing which is that
taiwan is basically only hoping that
uh advanced countries like the us is
going to
continue to help to approve these
military cells and it is not counting on
the foreign
powers to actually militarily intervene
because at the end of the day they think
that the responsibility
rests with the taiwanese military and
the tony's people
we'll leave it there for the time being
dw correspondent william yang in taipei